and continuing with the coverage of the
crash that killed nine in north las
vegas this past weekend now what the
national transportation safety board
says may be needed to prevent similar
events in the future
investigators say the at fault driver
may have been going more than a hundred
miles an hour running a red light
northbound on commerce at cheyenne
listen closely to what the ntsb's tom
chapman said monday about crashes
involving speed tragedies such as this
compel us to evaluate the potential for
improving safety
by incorporating speed limiting
technology in all vehicles yeah you
heard him the board may look into speed
limiting technology in all vehicles so
there are speed governors on some rental
trucks where they just won't go any
faster than 65 miles an hour but no word
on what a possible top speed might be on
passenger cars and of course any such
technology you have a lot of hurdles to
overcome sure wouldn't happen anytime
soon but it is a subject we'll be
talking more about in the future and i'd
like to hear what you think buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone here's the email address traffic 8
8newsnow.com